hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming through the very special
video series and we're going to be
talking about 21 different concepts to
help you boost your score on the a CT
math section so we're going to be going
through 21 concepts some of these you
might know really well you can go ahead
and skip on to the ones that are more
difficult to we're going to go through
them just one by one these are ones that
are commonly seen on the the tests it's
something you want to familiarize
yourself with and you might want to try
pausing the video doing the problem
first on your own and then checking it
to see you know how to solve it we'll do
it together in this video it's up to you
however you feel it's going to help you
best go ahead and approach it that way
let's get right started into this video
lesson okay talking about proportions so
proportions is an important concept
understanding the ECT and basically what
it is it's just a ratio that's equal to
a ratio so together that forms of
proportion so let's take a look at these
two examples go ahead and see if you can
solve them on your own and then we'll go
through them together so the first one
here
we're just saying okay what is the
circumference of this circle okay and
they give us the arc length is 10
centimeters so how would we do that
well we're going to make a proportion
the way we're going to do this is we're
going to say for every 90 degrees okay
see 90 degrees that's the part okay of
the entire circle and if we compare that
to the entire circle 360 degrees all the
way around okay that ratio is going to
be the same thing as this arc length 10
is to the entire circumference we'll
just call that C so again all we're
doing is we're just doing the part to
the whole equals the part to the whole
these two ratios are equal to each other
together they form a proportion and you
can cross multiply across the equal
signs that's what most students usually
do you can reduce this first if you want
I think I'll do that so that's 1 over 4
equals 10 over C and if I cross multiply
get C equals 40 and that's just going to
be centimeters okay so that's number one
number two this is just a another common
proportion type problem and that's where
you know it's a sunny day
and a shadow is being cast by a tree you
can easily measure the distance from the
base of the tree to the to the tip of
the shadow here let's just say that's 20
units 20 feet and say you're about 6
feet tall and say that your shadow is
about 4 feet in length so these two
triangles are similar to one another
which means that you get the
corresponding sides are proportional so
we're going to make a proportion here
and I'm just going to do the same thing
I'm going to say shadow to shadow
okay so the person's shadow to the tree
shadow is the same as the person's
height okay that ratio to the overall
height of a tree H and then all we're
going to do is we're just going to cross
multiply so we have 4 H equals 120 okay
so this diagonal multiplied together
equals that diagonal and then we're just
going to divide by 4 and you can see
that's going to be 30 feet okay that's
the height of the tree okay continuing
on to lesson number two in our acct math
series we're going to talk about
averages so here's the formula we're
going to be using over here to find the
average it's the total divided by the
number how many of the items that you
have that equals your average so when
you divide those two you get the average
the common example would be like if you
took 10 tests over the course of your
class and you add up all your points
that you scored on the tests you divide
by the 10 tests and that would give you
your average test grade you know per
test right now on the AC T they don't
always you know give it to you in a
straightforward fashion like that they
might ask you for what's the total of
all your test scores or they might ask
you for you know like how many tests did
you take if your average is this and
they give you this so they may give you
two of the three parts and you have to
find that missing component it won't
always just be straightforward with you
know the total divided by the number and
you just have to divide so I'll show you
in this example what I mean and you can
try to sign your own if you'd like so
this one it says if the total of your
calorie intake over the past six days is
11 thousand four hundred calories how
many calories would you need to consume
today to have eaten an average of 2,000
calories per day okay so to understand
the question base
sickly what we're trying to do is we're
trying to get an average intake of 2,000
calories per day so we know that's our
average that we're looking for 2,000 and
we know that there are seven days in a
week okay so for the total that for the
seven days so we're dividing by seven
but it looks like so far we've consumed
eleven thousand four hundred plus
whatever we're going to consume on that
seventh day we don't know what that is
so we're just going to make it a
variable or just going to call it X okay
so now what we can do is we can solve
this equation and we can do that by
cross-multiplying or you could just
multiply both sides by seven okay like
that so this equals 14,000 and then you
have eleven thousand four hundred plus x
equals fourteen thousand subtract the
eleven thousand four hundred from both
sides and that's going to give you two
thousand six hundred calories that you
need to consume on that seventh day to
bring your average up to 2,000 calories
per day so definitely want to memorize
the average equation average formula and
just keep in mind that it won't always
be in a straightforward fashion but just
go ahead and write down the formula
start substituting in what you know and
then you can solve for what you don't
know I'll see you in the next lesson
okay the third concept we're going to
talk about it's tested on the EC T is
probability so you want to understand
how to work with these basic probability
questions and the formula you want to
know is this one right here probability
equals the number of successes divided
by the total possible outcomes so a
quick example would be like if you had a
spinner okay like this and just say it
was divided into three sections one two
and three okay and you spin the spinner
and you say what's the probability that
you land on the number one
well there's one chance of success out
of three possible outcomes and you can
see these are all evenly divided so we
have an equal chance of landing on each
one of the three so your probability is
one-third one chance out of three okay
so that was kind of a very basic one
let's take a look at a little bit more
challenging one and this one here says
in a four digit lottery
okay one through ten where do just can
be repeated what is the probability that
you prick that you choose the correct
number pick the correct number well one
way to do analyze this is that how many
numbers are there well okay for the
first number there's basically one
through ten so you have ten
possibilities for the first digit since
you can get that same digit again
there's ten possibilities for the second
third and fourth and by multiplying
those together we know that there's
10,000 possible outcomes now there's
only one correct one so the probability
of guessing the right one would be one
chance okay of success out of 10,000
possible outcomes so your probability of
getting the right answer okay by just
guessing one time would be one out of
10,000 so again
probability number of successes divided
by the total possible outcomes if you
just take a note of how many there are
total and how many that you want those
are the successes and divide you can
calculate the probability okay concept
number four is multiplication counting
principle so what we're going to talk
about in this video is how to find the
total possible outcomes using the
multiplication counting principle we'll
take a look at an example see if you can
solve this one on your own
and it will go through it together so
for breakfast you choose either eggs or
cereal and then you choose to drink
coffee tea or milk and then you choose a
piece of fruit either an apple a pear or
a banana how many different breakfasts
are possible so one way to solve this
problem is to draw a tree diagram and
the way you can do that is just think of
it as you know a fork in the road you're
making a decision you're either going to
go with the eggs we're going to go with
the cereal right and then if you decide
to go with the eggs you could pick
coffee tea or milk okay so we have three
choices there coffee tea milk but if we
went over here with the cereal we still
have a choice of coffee tea or milk and
then once we make these decisions we
have three more we can either have an
apple pear or banana right so apple pear
apple pear banana apple pear banana
apple pear banana apple pear banana so
I'll just write those in real quick so a
pv AP b AP b and a p b now if you think
of this as kind of like a
choose-your-own-adventure if you go down
this branch then you can pick three
choices here and then three choices so
you could either end up going all the
way down here
all the way down over here but
eventually going to end up at one of the
ends of these branches and you can see
you can count them up there's 3 6 9 12
15 18 possibilities so there's 18
different breakfasts but you can see
that takes a long time to do that on the
acct you're obviously pressed for time
so the easier way to do this is just to
say okay i've got two choices for the
main part of my meal the eggs are the
cereal so that's two choices and then
i've got three choices for something to
drink so that's times three and then
we've got three choices for a piece of
fruit and if you multiply all these
together you can see 2 times 3 is 6
times 3 is 18 and we get the exact same
outcome this is just more of a visual
representation but in the interest of
time you just multiply how many choices
there are in each category and that'll
give you your total possible different
breakfasts in this case with a different
number of outcomes that you can have ok
moving right along the next concept
that's important to understand for the
AC T is our functions ok so functions in
the normal way that you learn them in
your math class look something like this
f of X equals you know in this case 2x
minus 7 and the way you solve this is
whatever is in the parentheses see the 3
here
that's your x value that's your input so
you're putting that X in place of X on
the right side of the equation and
you're simplifying so here you would
have 2 times 3 minus 7 which is negative
1 so f of 3 equals negative 1
so you have an input and then you
substitute on the right side and
simplify but on the ECT they want to
test you that you understand the concept
of how functions work with an input and
an output
but they put it in a slightly different
form that sometimes students aren't used
to seeing it
and I'll just show you an example here
see if you can solve this one if L
square M equals M squared minus l
squared what does - this is supposed to
be a square which is 2 square 7 equal
well
don't freak out when you see this symbol
you might think yourself we've never
learned this square what does this
represent right just see if you can
follow the pattern you can see whatever
here is in front of or to the left of
the square that's going to go in here
for L on the right side and you're going
to square it whatever is here to the
right of the square M okay is going to
go in here for em and you're going to
square it and then you're going to
subtract so just following the pattern
realizing that there's an input and then
that you know there's going to be an
output you're going to do a substitution
and solve so in this particular problem
if we just go ahead and solve it it
looks like - is our L value so that's
going to be 2 squared 7 is our M values
that goes here so that's 7 squared and
so we have 49 minus 4 which is 45 and we
got it so this is an easy one to get
right on a CT you just have to recognize
the pattern and if you're interested in
learning more about all these concepts
that we're talking about these 21
concepts I do have a course you can
check it out I'll have a link but we're
going to continue on going through the
21 concepts so let's go to the next ok
cruising right along we're going to get
into the next concept which is circles
and there's usually one of these
problems on a CT it's an easy one to get
right if you know the equation of a
circle so this is what you want to
memorize right here X minus H the
quantity squared plus y minus K the
quantity squared equals R squared
now HK is the coordinate of the center
of the circle and R is the radius of the
circle so we're going to do an example
and I'll show you what I mean you can
see if you can do this one on your own
first if you'd like and then we'll go
through it so X minus 7 squared plus y
plus 3 squared equals 64 what is the
center and the radius of the circle ok
do you have it alright so the center is
at positive 7
negative three now notice how it's the
opposite okay it's positive seven
negative three it's the opposite of the
sign it looks like minus seven but see
how this is X minus H so the H is just
seven and over here with y plus three
this is really like Y minus a negative
three so if you could remember it's just
the opposite you know sign so that's the
center of the circle and then the radius
you have to realize that this is
actually the radius squared here 64 so
by taking the square root the radius
equals eight now just to show you if you
wanted to graph this you're going to go
right seven and down three okay that's
the center of the circle right there and
then you're going to go you know to the
left eight units you're going to go to
the right eight units you're going to go
up eight units your new down eight units
and then you can draw the circle through
those you know four key points so
definitely want to know the equation of
a circle it's an easy one to get right
on the AC T let's move right on to the
next topic okay if you watch this far
I'm sure you're picking up some
excellent concepts that will help you
boost your score on the AC T just a
quick tip if you're studying and you're
practicing to take the AC T you
obviously want to take some of the
previously released tests I would go
through those tests you know time
yourself 60 minutes 60 questions for the
math portion and then you know go
through them and look at the ones that
you've gotten wrong just try to figure
out what you're not understanding and
then go ahead and after you iron out
some of those difficulties go ahead and
take another practice test well we're
going through here these 21 concepts
these are ones that students oftentimes
make mistakes on and just a little
little twist a little bit of
understanding you know how the problems
change slightly can make a big
difference in solving those problems
more quickly and of course more
accurately so in this next video we're
going to be talking about percentages
and this is something that you're
probably familiar with a little bit
already you know how to convert from a
percent to a decimal just by moving that
decimal point two places to the left
right but on the AC T what sometimes is
helpful is to think about how much more
than a hundred percent or how much less
than a hundred percent you know you're
working with so for example if you go to
a store and
everything's 30% off instead of focusing
on the 30% focus on the 70% that you're
actually going to pay for the items so
you could take an item that's $40
multiply it by the 70% and then you know
exactly what it is that you're going to
pay instead of figuring out what you're
saving and then subtracting it from the
original amount this is just allows you
to do it in one step by focusing on a
hundred percent minus the thirty percent
let's take a look at an example see if
you can do this one on your own and
we'll go through it always eager to
improve you you decide instead of
swimming your usual 30 laps that you'll
increase it by 10 percent today and then
by 20 percent more than that amount okay
that you swam today tomorrow how far
will you swim tomorrow so do you
understand the question it's basically
saying that you normally swim 30 laps
you know some 10% more today tomorrow
you're going to increase on your
previous amount okay so an additional 20
percent so the big mistake that students
often make is they'll just say well this
is 30 percent I'll just add these
together but that's not quite right what
you want to do in this problem is you
want to look at it from this perspective
you're increasing your distance by 10
percent that means you're swimming 110
percent of okay odd means times rate of
your previous amount the 30 laps okay
then you're taking this entire quantity
okay and you're increasing by an
additional 20 percent so that means
you're swimming 120 percent okay more
than this okay this whole quantity here
we're going to convert the percent to a
decimal so this is 30 times one point
one zero I'm just moving that decimal
point two to the left and then we're
multiplying this whole quantity times
120 percent which is one point two zero
now let's go to the calculator if we do
that I just want to show you something
really quick one point one times one
point two is actually one point three
two so what that means is you're
actually increasing you know the mouth
that you're swimming by 32% see not 30%
it's actually 32% and if you multiply by
a hundred thirty two percent
we're going to do it all in one step so
we're going to take 30 times 132 percent
which is thirty nine point six okay
so we're just going to say thirty nine
point six laps okay so that's how you
work with these percentage problems
think about a hundred percent plus or a
hundred percent minus and then take it
from there okay concept number eight you
want to take another look at when you're
preparing for the AC t-- math section is
factoring so hopefully remember all the
different types of factoring that there
are I'll just show you a couple in this
short segment but you might want to go
back and review some more factoring so
one type here is the difference of two
squares so a squared minus B squared so
a perfect square minus a perfect square
you factor like this a plus B times a
minus B it's a sum and difference
pattern another type where the leading
coefficient is one when you have a
trinomial like this you ask yourself
what two numbers okay multiply to C but
those same two numbers have to add to
this middle coefficient B so those are
just a couple of different types we'll
do a couple examples and then we'll take
it from there so 9x squared minus 100
one thing that jumps out at me right
away when I see this is that there's
only two terms so that means it's a
binomial and I notice that there's a
minus sign in between so it's a
difference and then the other thing that
jumps out of me is that these are two
perfect squares 9x squared is really 3x
times itself right and 100 is really a
perfect square because 10 times 10 and
all we have to do is make one of these
plus one of these - and we factored it
that's a difference of two squares
pattern this one here is a trinomial I
notice the leading coefficient is one so
I just have to ask myself what two
numbers multiply to negative 12 okay
I'll just diagram that out but at the
same time they have to add to this
middle coefficient which is negative one
it was negative X but you can just think
of that as a one negative one so that
looks like it's going to be negative
four and positive three so when we
factor this this is going to be X minus
four
X plus three and you can check your work
by distributing the X twice and
distribute the negative four twice and
then simplifying and you'll get back to
the original so this has just been a
little reminder to you about factoring
go ahead and review that a little bit
more and let's continue on to the next
lesson okay now we're going to look at
number nine the rules of exponents so on
the AC T they want to make sure that you
understand the basic rules of exponents
but like all the problems on the AC T
there's usually a slight twist that
makes it just a little bit more
challenging than what you learned in
your math class first let's go over the
rules of exponents then we'll do an
example problem so first things first
when you multiply and you have the same
base what do you do to the exponents you
add them when you divide and you have
the same base what do you do the
exponents you subtract them you take the
numerators power minus the denominators
power and you keep the base as it is
when you have something raised to a
negative exponent that negative exponent
doesn't make the number negative it just
tells you to take the reciprocal so you
can write this as 1 over X to the
positive n power anything to the 0 power
is 1 and then this last one when you
have a fraction raised to a power you
can distribute that power to the
numerator and the denominator so this is
X to the N divided by Y to the N so
let's look at a possible problem that
could be covered on the AC T and you can
see it's in a slightly different format
here it's a little bit more complicated
and we want to find M so see if we can
do this one and we'll go through it so
the first thing that I notice is we're
multiplying all these together and we
multiply what do we do to the exponents
we add them so this is going to be X to
the 2 plus 3 which is 5 plus M so X to
the 5 plus M over X to the 7th equals x
squared now what do we do when we divide
and we have the same base we subtract
the exponents so we have X to the 5 plus
M minus 7 equals x squared now you can
see that we have the same base ok so we
can set these exponents equal to each
other 5 minus 7 is negative 2 plus M
it must equal to so by adding 2 to both
sides of this equation you can see that
M equals 4 and that's our solution for M
so what made this a little bit more
challenging is that we had to do
multiple steps and we also had to set
the powers equal to each other because
we have the same base so this is one
possible problem that they can give you
on the AC T but again you want to make
sure you just review and understand
these rules of exponents
ok our number 10 concept is Pythagorean
triples so you probably already know the
Pythagorean theorem a B and C okay when
you have a right triangle a and B are
the two sides that make up that right
angle C is the hypotenuse that's the
longest side and we know that a squared
plus B squared equals C squared or the
sum of the legs squared equals the
hypotenuse squared but what you may not
know or may not remember are these
Pythagorean triples and here's for the
ones that come up the most on the AC T
and then the most common because they're
the smallest triples but there are
integers that form a right triangle okay
so three four and five if you take three
squared plus 4 squared that equals 5
squared 5 12 13 8 15 17 7 24 25 so the
number here on the end on the right
that's the hypotenuse that's the longest
side but what you want to realize is
that if you take any one of these
Pythagorean triples and you multiply all
the sides by the same number that will
also form a right triangle so for
example if I multiply all these by 2 6 8
and 10 these also form a right triangle
so by recognizing these you can save
yourself time when you're doing these
problems on the AC T I'll show you what
I mean in this example see if you can
solve this on your own
we've got a right triangle here and they
give us the two sides or the two legs 15
and 36 but they ask us to find the
hypotenuse X now you can go ahead and
substitute into the Pythagorean theorem
and solve for C and that's perfectly
fine but what you might want to do is
you might want to say well hmm what can
I divide both of these by what's the
greatest common factor well it looks
like I can do
I had a three out of both these okay
they both have a three in common so I
could write this as five and this is 12
so then what jumps out at me is that
this is a 5 12 13 Pythagorean triple
which means that this must be the 13
side but since I told these or multiply
these by 3 I have to multiply the 13 by
3 so that's 39 I went through and
explained it so it took a little bit
longer but you can do that very quickly
okay in your head or just by making a
quick note like I did did here but what
you want to do is you want to try to
divide out that greatest common factor
to reveal which one of the Pythagorean
triples that you're working with now
it's not always going to be a
Pythagorean triple but oftentimes on the
AC T they do use these common ones so
it's a time-saver and something that you
might want to review when you're
preparing for the test okay number 11
graphing lines and inequalities so you
probably learned a long time ago write
the slope-intercept form of a line y
equals MX plus B the M is the slope and
the B is the y-intercept where the line
crosses the y-axis but one thing I want
to remind you of in this particular
lesson is that when you're working with
inequalities you have to be careful
because you know you're going to be
shading one side of the plane you know
you're going to be shading you know
either above the line or below the line
or no to one side to the other and you
can use the test point method or you can
use another method I'm going to show you
in this particular example but
definitely knowing how to graph lines
and inequalities is an important concept
you want to review let's just look at a
simple example here 3x minus 2y is
greater than 6 now there's a couple
different ways to do this one way is to
rearrange the inequality and put it in
the y equals MX plus B form
but I'm not going to do it this way I'm
going to do it a slightly different way
I'm just going to set X to 0 and solve
for y by dividing by negative 2 so
that's negative 3 right so the
y-intercept is negative 3 and if I set Y
to 0 that means that X is 2 so that's
our x-intercept now you can see this is
greater than but not equal to so I'm
going to draw this as a dotted or a
dashed line it doesn't include the
points on the line now what you don't
want to do is you don't to make the
mistake of saying greater than oh I'm
shading above because that only works
the wise by itself if you have Y by
itself like Y is greater than something
something something then you can shade
straight above the line the Y values can
be greater than the Y values that are on
the line okay at that point at that x
value but here what I would do is I
would do a test point I'd say well let
me put in the origin here zero zero if I
put zero and zero in for X and Y I get
zero is greater than 6 is that true
no that's actually not true so where
this point is I don't want to shade on
this side of the plane I want to shade
on the other side so I'm going to shade
and that's going to be the solution set
for this inequality any point in this
region will make this inequality true
the other way you can approach this is
you can rearrange this you can say
alright I'm going to subtract 3x from
both sides ok I'm going to divide
everything by negative 2 to get the Y by
itself but remember when you multiply or
divide both sides of an inequality by a
negative number what happens to the
inequality sign it flips okay it changes
direction so now you can see this makes
sense this is why we're shading below ok
straight down below the line because Y
is less than okay so a couple different
ways to approach graphing inequalities
but again you might want to review how
to graph lines the slope-intercept form
graphing inequalities and this is
something that's tested on the AC T okay
number 12 we're going to talk about
equations of lines so on the AC T you
definitely want to know the different
forms of the equation of a line and just
to review we've got the slope-intercept
form y equals MX plus B we have the
point-slope form okay you can see why
1x1 is the point M is the slope and we
have the standard form ax plus B y
equals C so we're just going to go
through a typical example here and see
if you can do it on your own if you like
first and then we'll go through it
together we're going to take a look at
these two lines here and we're going to
ask ourselves are they parallel
perpendicular or neither ok so what
we're going to do is we're going to
analyze these two lines this one is in
the slope-intercept form because the Y's
by itself here already so that tells us
that the slope of this line is 2/3 okay
so that's the M right here
this one here though we need to
rearrange it we need to put it into the
slope-intercept form and we're going to
do that by subtracting 3x that's 2 y
equals negative 3x plus 6 we're going to
divide everything by 2 and so we get y
equals negative 3 halves X plus 3 okay
now we're going to analyze this this
line has a slope of 2/3 this line has a
slope of negative 3 halves when the
slopes are opposite reciprocals of each
other meaning they're the opposite sign
once positive ones negative and you take
the fraction you flip it over that means
its reciprocal of one another if they're
both opposite signs and reciprocals of
each other then it means that the lines
are perpendicular if they have the same
slope then the lines are parallel and if
it's neither then of course it's neither
so this is a typical problem that's
covered on the AC T but just knowing how
to rearrange the equations into the
slope intercept form will help you to
identify the the M value the slope and
then you can compare the lines to see if
they're parallel perpendicular or
neither okay number 13 is the slope so
you want to refresh or just remind
yourself of what the slope is it's the
rise over the run it's the you know
change in Y over the change in X it
gives you the angle of the line right or
if you have two points you can subtract
the two y-coordinates and then subtract
the two x-coordinates and divide but you
want to make sure that you're consistent
with that you either want to do y2 minus
y1 over x2 minus x1 or vice-versa y1
minus y2 divided by x1 minus x2 we'll
look at an example here what's the slope
through the points negative 6 2 & 4 8
okay so if we want to just label this
here you can see this is x1 y1 and x2 y2
so we're going to do y2 minus y1 8 minus
2 over x2 minus x1 4 minus a negative 6
so when you subtract it's like adding
the opposite so that gives us 10 8 minus
2 is 6 and we can reduce this to 3/5
that's the slope of our line
so again slopes an important concept you
want to know for the a seat
II just refresh on the formula and I
think you'll have it ok another
important concept to understand for the
math portion of the AC T is the midpoint
so you probably learn this formula
before in your math class if not just
it's easy to understand what you're
doing is you're averaging the exes and
you're averaging the Y's so you're just
adding the x-coordinates together and
dividing by 2
adding the y-coordinates together
divided by 2 and that will give you the
midpoint between two given points okay
so the halfway point now on the ECT they
have a way of you know just slightly
putting a little twist on the problem so
that you have to recognize oh they're
asking you for the midpoint you know
they're not necessarily going to come
out and say you know find the midpoint
so let's see if we can do this example
and you can do it on your own if you
like them and go through it or we can
just go through it here the airport is
seven miles west and 12 miles north of
your home halfway between your house and
the airport is a waterfall okay how many
miles west and north of your house is
the waterfall the waterfall located okay
what you might want to do in a problem
like this is just draw a diagram so if
we go over here and we just draw this on
a coordinate axis let's just say that
your home is right at the origin okay
for convenience and the airport is
located seven miles west
okay so never eat sour watermelon right
the northeast Southwest okay so it's
seven miles west okay so seven to the
west and twelve to the north of your
house okay so that means this point
right here where the airport is this is
negative seven positive twelve you're
going left seven okay and you're going
up twelve so we're just making this
negative because we're going to the left
and the twelve is positive because
you're going up so what we've done is
we've effectively coordinate eyes these
locations but what we're trying to do is
the waterfall is located halfway between
your house and the airport somewhere
right about there so we're going to use
the midpoint formula we're going to add
the two x-coordinates negative seven
plus 0 divided by two and we're going to
add the two y-coordinates twelve plus
zero okay / - so if we do that we get
negative three point five comma six so
it's three and a half blocks west of
your house
I'm sorry three and a half miles west of
your house and six miles north
so midpoint it's definitely important a
formula that you want to know for the AC
T something that's covered but again I
won't necessarily just come out and say
you know find the midpoint you may have
to coordinate eyes the points like I did
here and then you know go ahead and find
the midpoint and then interpret the
solution from there okay number fifteen
cruising right along we're going to talk
about logs now so logs is just something
that's just barely touched on in the AC
T usually there's maybe just one problem
and the main thing is knowing how to
switch from you know the logarithmic
form to the exponential form which we're
more familiar with and an easy way to
think about this is just to switch forms
is to do the inverse of the opposite so
what you could do is you could
exponentiate okay both sides using the
same base so exponential functions
logarithmic functions they're inverses
of each other they cancel one another
out and then X just equals B to the N so
we're going to do an example before I do
that I just want to mention that every
one of these 21 concepts could
potentially raise your score by one
additional point so even if you get a
handful of ideas out of this course this
mini-course here you can boost your
score by you know a number of points and
it can make quite a bit bit of
difference in your overall score I do
have an a CT math boost your score
course that's for sale if you're
interested in checking that out I have a
link for that you can also check my
channel home page I have a link there as
well and we're going to continue on
going through these 21 concepts this is
just an introduction I go a little bit
more in depth in the course I give you
some worksheets and some more teaching
and some more examples and so you'll get
a little bit more out of that course but
what I have here is just a sampling of
all the different topics to you'll get a
lot of benefit from this as well but if
you want to go deeper with it I
encourage you to check that out but
let's go ahead and solve this problem
and continue on with the with the 21
concepts so here we've got log base X of
25 equals
you we want to solve okay for the base
here so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to exponentiate okay I'm going to
raise both sides using base X because
exponential functions and logarithmic
functions they're inverse they cancel
one another and so now you can see x
squared equals 25 so that means that X
must be 5 okay so that's it so we solve
it so just knowing the basics about how
to work with logs is an easy way to
score an additional point on your test
let's go on to the next topic okay
number 16 we're going to be talking
about distance so distance is something
important to know for the AC T and the
formula for finding the distance is over
here x2 minus x1 squared plus y2 minus
y1 squared you add those two coins
together you take the square root and
that will give you the distance between
two points so on the AC T like most of
their problems they're not necessarily
straightforward like you learned them in
your math class and put a little twist
on it and that's the case here so in
this story problem let's see what they
give us your hair salon is two miles
east of your home and four miles north
your dance studio is five miles west of
your home and 20 miles south how far is
it in a straight line from your salon to
your studio ok good question so we want
to do is want to draw sketch kind of
like we did in the midpoint lesson and
coordinate eyes our points so here we're
thinking of north east south and west
and let's see your hair salon is two
miles east so we're going to to the east
and four miles north so it's like right
about here so that's 2 comma 4 2 to the
east 4 to the north and then your dance
studio is 5 miles west so we're going 5
miles this way and 20 miles south so
down here so that's negative 5 negative
20 now I'm using the negatives because
we're going left that's negative and
down that's negative and we want to find
this distance between the two so we're
gonna use our distance formula so we're
going to take 2 minus negative 5 2 minus
negative 5 squared plus 4 minus negative
20 okay
squared add those together and take the
square root so this is going to be
seven squared plus 24 squared take the
square root this is 49 plus let's see
576 which is 625 which equals 25 so it
would be 25 miles in a straight line
distance from here to here so I hope
that helped you understand the distance
form a little bit better but just a
couple of hints here about coordinate
izing the points and then using the
distance formula once you have the mass
coordinates and let's continue on to the
next lesson okay number 17 we're going
to talk about trigonometry so you
probably member this acronym from your
geometry or algebra 2 class the
sohcahtoa and all this means is that the
sine of an angle is the ratio of the
opposite side over the hypotenuse the
cosine of an angle is the adjacent side
over the hypotenuse and the tangent is
the ratio of the opposite side over the
adjacent so if this is your angle theta
opposite is across adjacent is next to
and the hypotenuse is across from the
right angle so I'll show you a typical
example and we'll go through it say you
want to solve for this missing side
right here X so they give us the angle
they give us a sign adjacent to the
angle and they give us a sign across
from the right angle the hypotenuse
that's what we want to solve for
actually as the hypotenuse so here we're
going to use the cosine because cosine
okay on 15 degrees equals the adjacent
side eight over the hypotenuse X now
just a quick note sometimes on the AC T
they might not actually have a numerical
value they might just say hmm let's just
leave that leave it in calculator ready
form and one thing to note is that when
you have a ratio equal to ratio like
this you can switch these quantities
here on the diagonal so I could write
this as x over 1 which is just x equals
8 divided by the cosine of 15 so this
could be one of your multiple-choice
answers it might not actually give you
the exact you know decimal approximation
they might just say 8 cosine 15 they
might even take it a step further and
the reciprocal of cosine get 1 over
cosine is secant the answer may even be
8 secant
fifteen degrees so this lesson has just
been to remind you a little bit about
how to work with the sine cosine and
tangent and just knowing this acronym
and knowing the ratios and then also
just kind of giving you a heads up about
you know the format of the answer it
might be just in a calculator ready form
okay
number 18 special right triangles so
this is definitely something important
you want to know for the math section of
the AC T the two you want to know are
the 30 60 90 and the 45 45 90 so if you
can remember these ratios the side
across on a 30 degree angle that's the X
side the one across from the 60 that's
the X square root three side and the one
across from the 90 that's the two X side
with the 45 45 90 this is an isosceles
triangle
both these legs are the same length but
the hypotenuse is the leg times square
root of two so just a quick review if
they give you the leg you multiply by
the square root of two to get that
potenuse they give you the hypotenuse
you divide by the square root of two and
over here if they give you the shortest
leg you double it to get the hypotenuse
multiplied by the square root of 3 to
get the longer leg they give you the
hypotenuse you divide by 2 to get the
shorter leg and then multiplied by the
square root of 3 to get the longer leg
they give you the longer leg you divide
by the square root of 3 to get the
shorter leg and then double to get the
hypotenuse so that's a quick overview of
the 30-60-90 45-45-90 let's look at a
couple examples here so this one we're
solving for y and i can see it's a
30-60-90 triangle this is the X square
root of 3 side here so to get to this
side I have to divide by the square root
of 3 okay now to get from the shorter
leg to the hypotenuse I have to double
that so this is going to be 12 divided
by the square root of 3 but you don't
want that square root in the denominator
so we're going to rationalize it so
that's 12 square root of 3 over 3 to 12
and the 3 reduce so this is just going
to be 4 square root of 3 this one you
see how these two sides are the same and
this is a right triangle that tells us
that this is a 45-45-90 triangle they're
giving us the hypotenuse 10 so we have
to divide by the square root of 2 to get
back to the leg so if we rationalize
again for this one we get 10 square root
of 2 over 2
the 10 of the to reduce and we just get
5 square root of 2 so try and remember
and memorize and review these special
right triangles if you need to these are
two that are covered on the test knowing
this can definitely improve your score
by a couple of points it might just be
used in the context of a problem not
just a problem on its own but just like
as part of a problem but knowing this
will save you some time okay number 19
we're going to talk about perimeter area
and volume and this is just a reminder
that you know it's important to know
these concepts on the acct knowing
perimeter area and volume so we'll just
go over the formulas real quick here and
that's for a circle you want to know the
circumference two PI R or pi times
diameter and the area equals PI R
squared a trapezoid you add the two
bases these are the parallel sides times
the height that's the perpendicular
distance times one-half that's the area
for a triangle you do the base times the
height times one-half for the volume of
a pyramid
you do one-third the area of the base
whatever shape this is you find the area
if it's a square or triangle or hexagon
times the height okay for a cylinder the
volume equals the area of the base PI R
squared times the height the surface
area equals two PI R squared that's the
two circles plus two pi RH that's the
lateral area or the sides in a cone the
volume equals 1/3 PI R squared times the
height and I'll just maybe mention one
quick example that comes up on the AC T
and that's it sometimes they'll ask you
for the perimeter of something that
looks like this and there's a little
trick to it and that's that they'll give
you some of these dimensions but what
you can do is you can think of these
pieces as being separated or
disconnected what you can do is you can
actually move them like this okay and
take this piece over here and move it
over and what you can actually do is you
can actually make this into a rectangle
which makes it a lot easier to find the
perimeter you just add up all the sides
and that's the perimeter instead of just
adding each of these individual ones you
can think of the segments as being
disconnected and you can make it into a
more convenient
rectangle problem like this oftentimes
comes up in the practice tests on the
ECT so that might be something you might
want to think about and then also just
review these formulas so that you're
you're prepared okay number 20 we're
going to talk about parallel lines and
angles so you probably member this from
your geometry class your algebra class
where you have two parallel lines and
that's what these little arrows indicate
is that they're parallel cut by a third
line called the transversal and there's
eight angles that are formed what you
want to know are which angles are
congruent which angles are supplementary
now the ones that are across from each
other like 1 & 4 2 & 3 5 8 & 6 & 7 those
are called vertical angles and those are
congruent the other angles are called
corresponding angles if you take these
four angles here and you place them on
top of these see how this forms an axe
if you place that axe on top of that X
the angles that match up those are
called corresponding angles and those
angles will be congruent to each other
the other two that we want to pay
attention to are the alternate interior
angles that's like 3 & 6 4 & 5 interior
means are in between alternate means
ones on the left ones on the right so
these are alternate interior and those
are congruent and then 1 & 8 2 & 7
those are alternate exterior angles and
those are also congruent and the other
angles like for example 2 & 4 see how
they form a straight line that's called
the linear pair those are supplementary
or like 4 & 6 or 3 & 5 those are
supplementary those are what are called
consecutive interior angles so you might
just want to review this particular
diagram parallel lines cut by a
transversal in preparation for the AC T
but we'll take a look at an example here
and I'll just show you how to approach
it you can see these two lines are
parallel and these two lines are
parallel and sometimes what helps us to
extend the lines a little bit just so
you can see that diagram over there jump
out at you a little bit more in the
diagram here so you can see that these
two angles are alternate interior angles
so this is 30 this is 30 also you know
in a triangle all the angles add up to
180 which means that this angle must be
30 as well as it adds up to 180 and then
if you look at it from kind of rotate
this these two
angles here are alternate interior
angles that means that this is 30 these
add up to 60 which means that this angle
is 120 these form a linear pair so that
means that x equals 60 so you can work
your way through the diagram like that
using alternate interior angles vertical
angles linear pairs and so on but this
is just a reminder to review this
diagram here and all the different types
of angles whether they're congruent or
complementary supplementary that sort of
thing okay we've reached the 21st
concept on a CT math boost your score
and I hope you've been enjoying this and
I hope I hope this is going to help you
increase your score on a CT so subscribe
to the channel I encourage you to do
that if you want to learn more and you
want to get more practice and see more
examples and more of my teaching
specifically about the a CT I do have a
course I'll have a link for that or you
can check it out on my channel header
page but let's get into this last
example and that's talking about how to
solve inequalities when you solve
inequalities it's just like solving an
equation you want to get the variable on
one side and the number on the other but
the one thing that sometimes students
get a little bit confused on is what
happens when you multiply or divide by a
negative number and what happens is that
the inequality sign will change
direction but it's only if you're
multiplying or dividing it doesn't
affect it if you're adding or
subtracting negative numbers just
multiplying and dividing so I'll show
you in this example how I would approach
this I'm going to add the 3x over here
to the other side okay just to get the
variables on one side and the numbers on
the other so that gives us 6x and
negative 18 then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to divide by 6 okay and that's
going to be negative 3 now notice I
didn't change the sign this number is
negative but I didn't divide by a
negative number so only if you divide or
multiply by negative number does that
sign change but what I am going to do
for my final result is I'm going to take
this inequality I'm going to flip it
over because I want the variable to be
on the left so this is going to be X is
less than negative 3 you can see it's
still pointing to the X like it was in
the step before okay but now I've got
the variable on the left so I took that
whole thing and I flipped it over so
that now we can see what X is X is less
than negative 3
and we've got it but just remember when
you're solving these multiply or divide
by a negative number the inequality sign
flips I want to wish you the best of
luck on a CT